champion  incredible these young Indians reaction  from him you know he's just cursing and  he knows it's all over it's gone one  slip up that was it and uh just like a  house of cards his position just  completely fell apart and he had 12  minutes when he blundered uh I mean he  would have known he was doing well  Magnus you can see he knew he was almost  winning or at least a pawn or two up for  nothing  and yeah we've all been there we've all  blundered but it is a bit careless maybe  to  to blunder Without Really pausing for  thought without looking for the  opponent's moves without calculating oh  he just wants to hide Magnus Carlsen he  hates the way he made that blunder and  imagine for cash sistering there waiting  now for six minutes  to make his move it's a shame his  camera's so dark because I would have  liked to have seen  special  expression Magnus is giving us a lot of  facial